(audience clapping)
- Good evening, everyone.
It is really my distinct
pleasure and privilege
to be with all of you tonight,
here, as we celebrate
the Academy's 14th
Annual Governor's Awards.
(audience clapping)
We are looking forward to
a beautiful night ahead,
as we come together
after a year challenged
by unprecedented heartache
and struggle for many,
both within our industry
and also around the world.
We know though that light
can always find its way into darkness,
and tonight, we hope
to bring you some light
by celebrating four icons of our industry
who have each brightened our lives
through their immeasurable
contributions of joy,
transcendent moments of beauty
and numerous pathways for finding awe.
Thank you all for sitting down
and being quiet in the back.
Appreciate it.
This is in fact what we,
as film artists, can do,
inspire awe.
A professor who studied the
transformative power of awe
says it can be derived from many sources,
of course, nature, music,
art, religion.
But the one that I find most
resonant to our community
is through what he calls
collective effervescence.
In each corner of the world,
countless individuals
sitting in a movie theater
have experienced that ineffable gift
of collective effervescence.
And perhaps, tonight, we
shall have a taste of it, too.
Each of our honorees has
contributed to that gift
in one way or another.
With Angela Bassett, it has
been through her magnetic
and mesmerizing performances.
(audience clapping)
With Mel Brooks, through his prolific work
as both a master comedian
and producer. (clapping)
(audience clapping)
With Carol Littleton,
through her magical touch in storytelling
and many years of service
to the academy.
(audience cheering)
What a beautiful room.
And with Michelle Satter.
(audience cheering)
Through expanding and drawing
brilliant new horizons
for so many artists.
Many of you this evening
are members of our Academy,
you understand the innate
value of close collaboration
and community building in our work.
You have shared with us how
important it is, therefore,
to come together in person,
whether it be for screenings,
or to discuss the pressing
issues of our industry,
or by attending celebratory
events like this one,
where we express particular
admiration and gratitude
for the contributions of
four amazing individuals
carefully chosen by our
esteemed Board of Governors.
I could not be more honored
to help lead this organization
along with Academy CEO,
Bill Kramer. (clapping)
(audience cheering)
And we are so fortunate to be supported
by the stellar work
done by so many of our members and staff,
not just tonight,
not just during Oscar season,
but day in and day out,
365 days a year. (clapping)
(audience clapping)
I'd also like to take
a moment to thank Rolex
for its generous support.
(audience clapping)
Both this evening
and of the Academy and
our museum year round.
Rolex's commitment to the arts
and sciences of filmmaking
is paramount to furthering
our important work.
Thank you also to the
wonderful Jennifer Fox.
(audience clapping)
For, again, producing
such a beautiful night for us.
We're deeply grateful for
her creativity and support.
And special thanks to our
brilliant Academy staff
and production teams
for their incredible work.
Also, thanks to our four ASL interpreters
for supporting us to make this evening
accessible to all. (clapping)
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
And please also welcome alumni
from our GOLD mentorship program
who are acting as our trophy presenters.
(audience member laughing)
(audience clapping)
Thank you all so much for joining us.
I would like to toast
each and every one of you,
and wish you a most extraordinary evening.
(upbeat music)